vice versa que rivers en allemand woerth
veut dire saucisse et l'allemagne peut
se vanter d'avoir créé plus de 1000 type
de saucisses qu'est ce que ça représente
la saucisse ou les allemands les
autrichiens est un plat qui est très
très populaire c'est très populaire oui
c'est vrai et riez bon quand même bon
show 6 avec une chope août avec sept ans
- 21
c'est qu'entre le foot c'est fantastique
la boucherie atlantique c'est une
histoire de famille werner lustig est
l'un des propriétaires charcutier dans
les années cinquante six mon père était
juste différent et il est venu avec le
bateau et le canada avaient un programme
qui permettait que les personnes avec
une métiers peuvent venir ici et qu'on
l'arrivée ils avaient un travail tout de
suite sur ces larrons il y avait de
travail tout de suite tu t'es ce qui
faisait qu'on travaille il était bouché
tu te bouges et douchez ont dit das volk
une flèche avec ça c'est le comme la
bible des saucisses c'est devant un bon
référencement oui il avait il est venu
avec ça
dans ces pays 6h30 du matin
c'est ici dans le sous-sol du commerce
qu'on fabrique depuis 1962 des produits
allemands dont plusieurs saucisses
on prend de susciter des bons cooper moi
je travaille beaucoup avec le boeuf et
le veau mais il ya aussi du port mais ça
c'est les trois choses on met aussi des
épices
werner rempli des boyaux et des boyaux
de préparations à la viande pour
fabriquer deux des saucisses allemandes
les plus populaires la cnacg perth et la
frankfort
j'en ai des clients qu'ils ont fait un
voyage en allemagne ou en autriche
il revient et dit j'ai mangé quelque
chose deux barres c'était tellement bon
eh bien oui c'est cela ici dans - 12 m
chez williams j water lit ça si c'est
aussi une histoire de famille alexandre
cusson et le fils d'un des fondateurs en
face il faut aussi le fruit de
l'imagination de trois ans faire
monde en 1986 1 les frères veulent la
paix seul des trois petits cochons les
deux frères non ça va être plus
international que ça soit pas juste du
port d'autres viandes et donc l'idée a
été de donner un nom aux trois petits
cochons
donc il ya william joseph et walter qui
a fait de william joie dans un comptoir
bien garni avec bien sûr et ce six
albums dans les saucisses allemandes ce
qu'on appelle une vice vol ce qui est
une saucisse blanche fait principalement
de vous une noire c'est quoi la course
une saucisse plus traditionnels c'est
une saucisse sachets créé très finement
c'est un mélange de viandes
habituellement par deux veaux selon ils
peuvent en quelques variations de ce
côté-là peu dépis légèrement fumé on a
également une variante qui s'appelle l'
oktoberfest en fait une blanche avec un
petit pariente
on y rajoute du persil et du poivre noir
c'est ce que nous avons comme vraiment
typiquement allemand quand quelqu'un
allemand ou quelqu'un qui désire des
produits vraiment très traditionnel en
fait les airs offrir
la meilleure façon de les réchauffer
différentes écoles de pensée
qu'additionner lmnp c'est dans l'eau
chaude
un suisse allemand vous dirai pas mal de
les otsi je dirais mamane combinaison
des deux ils sont déjà cuites et partir
à l'eau chaude et ensuite les rôtir
ça permet de revenir l'intérieur tendre
l'extérieur aussi un coût on a juste
besoin à réchauffer et se met dans l'eau
froide réchauffe le quand l'eau est
juste on tient n'a commencé à bouillir
met à côté maître l'a couvert laisse
laisse encore dans l'eau si vous voulez
pas deux ou cinq minutes comme tout le
monde est prête pour manger le cul river
et le plan climatique allemand par
excellence c'est une saucisse conçu
poudre de cari ou servie avec un ketchup
au curry ya le curieux c'est venu très
très populaire en allemagne s'était pas
toujours comme ça c'est quelque chose
qui est venu avec le temps avec le curé
vous serez l'itc cnac ouest qui était
chauffé dans l'eau en coupe très dans
plus de morceaux en met un saut ce dont
nous on a juste ketchup et en mange avec
les bonnes frites et c'est un fast-food
aimons populaire parce que la bosse à
tous les coins de rue c'est un peu comme
la poutine c'est ça je pense qu'il ya
quand même des touristes qui mangera pas
seulement des allemands
je fais ce matin ce au plus frais que ça
vous trouvez pas en tout la ville de
montréal danks commence pétition
[Musique]